when you become a Navy SEAL it isn't
that you pray for war it's that you hope
for an opportunity to actually put your
skills to the test and I remember we had
just found out that we were going to get
to go to Afghanistan and one of our more
senior guys who had done several
deployments all to Afghanistan and Iraq
it just looked like he was really
disappointed to hear we were going to
Afghanistan and so I walked up to him
and I was like why aren't you excited
about this I'm a brand new guy and he's
like because someone's going to die
that's what happens you go to these
places someone here right now is going
to get killed at least one to that point
my whole journey to be seal was very
Charmed I mean like it's pretty
incredible to say I'm going to be an nav
seal and then go through all the
training and become an nav seal but it
was like now I'm seeing the reality of
the job I will say fortunately our
platoon did not lose anyone on our
deployment there were several people
hurt actually including me but that set
the tone for me going into the
deployment I started to look at it more
not as a scared but more realistic yeah